[Music]
abortion has long been a flash point in
america's culture walls
like gun control it's an issue that
divides almost exactly down party lines
the country's conservative republicans
mostly identify as pro-life
[Music]
while its liberal democrat voters
identify themselves most often as
pro-choice
[Applause]
after decades of push and pull on both
sides of america's abortion debate has
it finally reached a tipping point
[Music]
abortion is legal in every state in
america but restrictions and access vary
a woman's right to abortion is protected
in law across the country by ruling from
america's highest court in the case of
roe versus wade 1973
in that case the supreme court found
that a set of texts and laws
criminalizing abortion violated a
woman's constitutional right to privacy
[Music]
pro-lifers have struggled to overturn
america's abortion laws because of the
way its legal system works there have
been several challenges to roe versus
wade some of which have limited but not
overturned it only the supreme court can
overturn the law that gives women the
right to abortion
nine judges sit on the court they are
politically appointed by the president
and served for life
there's traditionally been a balance of
conservative and liberal judges but
under donald trump that changed
he unbalanced the court by appointing
three conservative judges the balance is
now six three in favor of the more
traditional right
america's religious right made up mostly
of catholics and evangelicals is vast
and well funded they've campaigned
tirelessly to overturn roe versus wade
which they believe violates the sanctity
of life
since 2011 states have passed nearly 500
laws restricting abortion
to access to texas and beyond
republican legislatures are waging a war
in may 2021
texas introduced a controversial new
bill that's a bill that i'm about to
sign that ensures that the life of every
unborn child who has a heartbeat will be
saved from the ravages of abortion
[Applause]
senate bill 8 has been dubbed the
heartbeat bill because it bans abortion
once a fetal heartbeat has been detected
and that can be as early as six weeks
senate bill 8 says we're going to
protect that little life when there's a
heartbeat when there's a fetal heartbeat
you know the heartbeat is the universal
sign of life it's controversial as women
often don't know they're pregnant at
this stage and there are no exceptions
for pregnancies resulting from rape or
incest the heartbeat bill differs from
previous abortion laws which were
enforced by the government this bill
allows everyday private citizens to sue
abortion providers like doctors but also
taxi drivers who may take a woman to an
appointment they can sue for at least
ten thousand dollars with no limit on
the number of lawsuits that can be
brought about there is
a bounty now on
helping someone get an abortion it's
creating vigilante bounty hunters now
across the country
anti-abortion activists have celebrated
and hailed the bill calling it vital
it's a beautiful thing
it's innovative it's
[Music]
while
strategic
groups have vowed to fight the bill
which forces texan women who want an
abortion to drive an average of 248
miles to reach a clinic
president joe biden condemned the bill
and it just seems i know this sounds
ridiculous almost un-american
and the u.s justice department is suing
the state of texas in an attempt to
block it the obvious
and expressly acknowledged intention of
this statutory scheme
is to prevent women from exercising
their constitutional rights
the democrat majority house of
representatives have passed the women's
health protection act to protect women's
access to abortion in every state
but it's unlikely to pass the senate
at the end of 2021 the supreme court
will hear a case from mississippi where
abortion is currently banned after 15
weeks
it's likely to be the first time the
newly right-leaning supreme court has
considered a challenge to roe versus
wade it could lead to drastically
different abortion laws across america
[Music]